welcome to another technology tuesday
and today i'm answering a question about
facebook i'm going to be doing a
facebook page review for one of my
youtube fans who wrote in to say my name
is etienne my biggest dream to create
magical animated stories teach others
how to do so as well the facebook page
i've created for awareness isn't really
visited all that much organically do you
have any suggestions it's vanemden
productions on facebook thanks in
advance even for simply reading this so
we're going to check out his page and
give him some advice on how to get more
results from facebook
so i did a search and this is the page
here and i guess there he is and there's
his uh
creation the bear
and
you know looking at this originally so
we've got 336 likes uh where magical
stories come to life you know right away
i need something that hits me so i see
the bear smiling i see you know
you hear
i like something
you know this magic if that's your thing
i like something a little more magical
right what can you put in here that's
more magical that gives me that feeling
this kind of reminds me of some of the
early walt disney stuff where he's
hanging out talking to mickey mouse but
when you look at
at anything disney now you get that
magical feeling and i think that seems
to be what you're focused on is let's
let's make some magic have a magical
weekend so everything
magic is one word you're one word you
gotta let that flow and i've even put it
somewhere on here what i'd love to
have you really figure out is
you know why is the world missing magic
why is magic important why do i need to
care about magic and and
have that flow through everything that
you post again you want to make me feel
something when i come to your page and
get me involved and make me
make me sign up for the magical movement
why do i care about this right so have
that come through loud and clear and you
have this opportunity here at the top of
your page to to share that with me so
your credo something your mantra
something that makes me feel something
stand for something here
then i'm looking down here so let's look
at some posts so magical weekend you
know i love this uh july 19th so now
it's i'm recording this on august 13th
so
it's been almost a month since you
posted anything so that's not that's not
good we got to have a more frequent
schedule
but but i like this if this was posted
on a friday you know there's you and the
bear it symbolizes me looking off into
the sunset it's great
this post
did very well 103 people liked it it's
in dutch so i don't really understand
what's happening but it sounds like you
did some kind of promotion for it since
you said you weren't able to get any
organic stuff for it
so let's skip this keep your eyes on the
ball dundee so i guess here you're
sharing some animations you're working
on
something else in dutch
thanks a bunch for the wonderful promos
here you have your bear
with somebody else that's great and that
got a lot of
likes and some comments
again in dutch
you see the goals of slowly but surely
form one big happy family of various
artists to combine their wonderful
talents to create true enduring magical
experiences for the young and those
young at heart see this is great this
mission that you have if i'm an artist
and i want to create magical experiences
for people
now i know that i can come to you and we
can partner up this needs to be way more
front and center this this needs to be a
little more powerful and lead with this
because then i want to hit your page
right away and be like yeah i want to be
a part of this
i'm a big fan of the magic art form
animation
so only two on that this is i guess what
you and your dad 17 on that not bad
another magical weekend see these ones
do well they're fun they have uh you
know a purpose you want people to have
some magic happen this week and it's
great
it's really been a long time since you
last posted so okay so summarizing this
magic thing this has to be more front
and center it has to make me feel
uh connected to it
more quickly and every single post that
you put up okay next we want to have a
posting schedule because you're kind of
all over the place so you haven't posted
for a month you're apologizing for not
posting you gotta have a consistent
schedule if even if it's just once a
week so people know to expect something
once per week keep that consistent i
love the posting of the bear with with
people so if it's of you and when you
were a kid or this woman you had
somewhere here here that's great and
maybe maybe you post the bear with
people who are doing magical things and
you share their story right there's
artists that you want to expose or if
there's famous uh people you look up to
who you think
epitomize magic for you and you want to
showcase them and you share their story
with the bear right so i mean robin
williams just passed away recently i
don't know if you think he's a magical
person or not maybe it's the bear with
robin williams there's a lot of people
that you can showcase both famous and
not famous yet to showcase their stories
and when you do that you're going to get
you know some engagement with it
so i think that's your starting point
you know again we we want to have magic
flow through everything have a of a
strong purpose up front so i understand
what it is you do and why i'm going to
be attracted to you have a number two
have a regular posting schedule that
keeps me coming back that post
important information where it's not
just promotional stuff but
the the criteria needs to be
when you post something you feel
proud you know like yeah i made that i'm
excited that i just launched this
creation into the world you know you're
an artist you're you're doing
these animations with this bear every
post you create for your facebook page
needs to also have just as much love and
and that feeling of proudness that yeah
i made this this is gonna do some good
in the world
and then i'd expand to have the bear be
with other people and be a part of
causes and artists and people that you
stand by and share their stories tell me
why it's important tell me why these
people are magical and and give me a
teachable lesson right so i see this
post and then what am i supposed to do
with that
right how is that going to inspire me to
be
more magical why do i need this in my
life if you can get to that point and
you're close i think you have the
elements here you're a lot further along
than a lot of people but if you can get
to that point where
i want more magic in my life and and i'm
gonna get it by coming to your page so
you have to make me feel that
so that's my advice i'm i'm kind of on
the on the border here you know i like
the concept
i wish it was all in english and that
may be a challenge for people if you're
coming and it's you know half the posts
are in dutch if you're trying to reach a
broader market but you know i'm kind of
on the fence looking at this page i i
could get behind the magic movement i
want you to make me feel a little bit
more and if you do with your with your
next post and you know changing the page
around then then uh i could see myself
giving this page a like and starting to
get involved i like the bear i like
where you're going with it uh so do some
work and keep me posted for those of you
watching you like the video you can
support me by clicking on the link in
the description leave a comment let me
know what you think about this page and
you can click on my face in the corner
top corner of this video to subscribe to
my channel and see more videos like this
thank you guys so much and i'll see you
soon